[Music]
hi mystery recap here today i am going
to explain an episode called white
christmas from the british science
fiction series black mirror
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the episode begins in a tiny cabin in
the middle of nowhere joe potter wakes
up on christmas eve to loud music
playing outside his roommate matt trent
is in the christmas spirit but joe is
not in the mood for it matt and joe have
been living together for five years but
have barely talked to each other matt
asks joe his reason for being in the
cabin but he is hesitant to talk so matt
goes first to ease joe into the
conversation he starts talking about his
life prior to living in the cabin
matt used to be a love guru someone who
helped nervous boys to flirt with women
and seduce them he used an advanced
technology fitted into the eyes of the
man called the z eyes to watch how the
date went and listen to their
conversations
matt talks about one particular case of
a man named harry harry is a nervous man
around girls and needs matt's help to
seduce one it is night time and harry
has to get ready to crash a random
office party matt starts by turning the
z-link on now he can see and hear
everything that harry does he asks harry
to change from his clothes to something
more masculine harry obliges and gets
ready when he first gets into the party
harry looks around and his eyes land on
a dark-haired girl hanging out with a
blonde girl and a man
matt advises him to join the group but
talk only to the blonde girl he does a
reverse image search to look for the
girl's name and personality on a device
the blonde introduces herself as amy and
the other girl as jennifer jennifer then
excuses herself and leaves the
conversation harry goes to the washroom
and asks matt not to watch while he pees
just then we get to know that matt isn't
alone but a whole group of his friends
are watching the interaction online when
harry goes back jennifer is sitting
alone far from the party matt makes him
approach her jennifer finally seems to
be opening up to him while talking she
reveals that she used to take pills but
isn't taking them anymore the statement
unsettles harry and matt but they don't
think much of it jennifer goes to the
bathroom and harry starts talking to
matt he genuinely likes the girl and
feels like he is cheating her by taking
matt's help as he chats jennifer returns
and sees him talking to himself she
immediately asks him to come over to her
place and harry obliges
she claims that the little voice in her
head is asking her to invite him when
they reach her home jennifer goes to get
drinks after telling harry to go to her
room the guys watching them are excited
anticipating sexual advances from her
but harry retaliates saying that he
isn't comfortable with matt watching
jennifer comes back with the drinks and
demands harry get on the bed he
hesitantly agrees when suddenly she
forces him to take a gulp of the drink
jennifer thinks that harry too has
voices in his head and assumes harry is
insane like her turns out she has
poisoned the drink to kill herself and
harry so they don't have to hear the
voices anymore
matt and the others watching are
horrified when harry starts coughing
blood she eventually forces him to drink
the juice and kills him matt quickly
turns his computer off and asks the
other guys to destroy any video evidence
they have of the interaction
matt gathers the evidence in a bin and
sneaks out of the room to throw them out
however he is caught by his wife claire
she finds out about his involvement with
the crime and him being a perverted love
guru the two get into a fight and claire
blocks him with the new technology of
human blocking the person being blocked
will only appear as an anonymous shape
to the blocker the two cannot talk or
communicate back in the present matt
reveals that being a love guru was his
side hustle his main job was somewhat
unusual he starts by talking about a
woman named greta she is sitting on a
hospital bed when a nurse comes and asks
if she is ready to perform the procedure
when the process starts greta falls
unconscious under anesthesia then we see
something being taken out of the woman's
head a nurse keeps an egg-like device on
the table the device has a mind of its
own that we can hear her talking it
turns out greta's whole memory has been
coded and put into the device so now the
egg is a second greta that cannot move
but still has her consciousness and
personality in the following scene the
device is in front of matt he explains
to the voice that he works for a company
called smart intelligence the company
has figured out a way to make digital
clones of people and store them in an
egg-shaped object the clones are called
cookies and are used as personal
assistants by real people the real greta
has made her cookie to help her through
daily life a control panel in front of
the cookie controls everything in the
house like the temperature lighting and
all the electronics she has to use them
to help greta with basic things however
the cookie refuses to be a slave to
greta matt has expected this so he sets
a one minute timer on the device during
this time the cookie greta will live one
year of life in one minute when the
minute is over and matt talks to her
again she is startled after spending a
year in isolation she begs matt to give
her something to work on matt happily
says that she will be working as greta's
assistant from now on we see then the
cookie monitoring the real greta she
turns the light and alarm on in the
morning she makes a shot of espresso for
her and makes a voice narrate her
schedule that is her life now back in
the present joe finally feels
comfortable and starts opening up about
his life he had a beautiful fiance named
beth on a snowy day the two go out as
beth's father tells them to be back home
soon in the following scene we see beth
and joe having dinner with two of their
friends beth doesn't feel good after
dinner so she goes to sleep early as joe
cleans after her he spills the contents
of the bin and finds a positive
pregnancy kit shocked he confronts beth
about it she dismisses it and says that
she wants an abortion and is too young
to have a kid joe tries to convince her
saying that he will take care of the kid
but beth is strictly against it when he
starts to scream at her she blocks him
joe's voice changes into a muffled tone
and the two only see a shadow of each
other now he throws a vase at the wall
and storms out of the room the following
morning beth rushes to her car outside
while a still blocked joe follows her
beth drives away somewhere and never
comes back the block stops joe from
calling or texting her so he has no
means of communication a week passes but
she doesn't return
joe learns that she has left the job
without any explanation and no one knows
where she is moreover he cannot even
look at images of her as the block
option covers every image of the person
a few months later he is in town when he
sees a silhouette nearby and recognizes
it as beth's it is clear to him that she
is still pregnant surprised that she has
kept his child he approaches her and
asks her to turn the block off but all
beth hears is a muffled voice and yells
for help eventually the police arrest
joe he is desperate to meet his child
but doesn't know where beth is he knows
where her father lives and is sure that
beth is going to be there at christmas
so next christmas he goes to her
father's home which lies in the middle
of nowhere there he finally sees beth
and their kid since the block option
blurs offspring as well he cannot see if
the baby is a boy or a girl joe is
beyond confused as to why beth kept the
baby but doesn't want him in her life a
lot of time goes by joe has made it a
ritual to visit beth's father every
christmas eve and look at them from a
distance he claims it was like watching
his kid grow up even though he couldn't
see the kid's face four years later he
realizes that the child is a girl for
the first time one day joe is searching
through channels on the tv and sees
beth's picture on it she had died in a
train crash so the block was turned off
joe can see her face for the first time
in years the next christmas he wraps a
christmas globe as a present for his
daughter and heads to beth's
grandfather's home when he gets a
glimpse at her he is sure she is not his
daughter shocked he follows her into the
house he realizes beth had been cheating
on him with her co-worker beth's father
is shocked to see him at his house and
asks him to go away in anger and
frustration joe hits the old man with
the snow globe injuring his head joe
left the old man unconscious in the
kitchen and never came back he died in
this very spot and the little girl
stayed in her room for the day the
following day she gave her dead
grandfather a gift she had made him
realizing that no one is going to come
she went out to search for help while it
was snowing heavily since the house was
in the middle of nowhere she died of
cold as he finishes telling the story
joe is in tears he asks god to forgive
him
matt asks him if he confesses his crime
and joe admits that he does he seems to
be in an interview with joe at this
point all of a sudden matt talks to
someone else claiming that he has done
it and asking them to let him out now
the scene changes to matt at a police
station talking to some officials in
front of him lies an egg-like cloning
device as it turns out matt has been
talking to joe's cookie this whole time
using the technology he created his own
cookie to try to make joe confess his
crime matt had made a deal with the
police that if he can make joe confess
he will be let free for not reporting
harry's death and conducting illegal
dating services the police say that he
will be on their sex offender list and
will be permanently blocked from
everyone when matt goes out he sees that
everyone around him is just a silhouette
the world is blurred and muffled for him
moreover everyone sees him as a red
shadow indicating that he is a sex
offender a police officer sets a timer
of a thousand years per minute on joe's
device and leaves him like that the
cookie joe now lives a thousand years in
one minute in isolation we see him
struggling to keep himself sane as the
camera pans out he seems to be inside a
loop of snow globes subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching